thank you for choosing my talk and
coming to this room you're all awesome
and it's you know let's let's make them
like you said jealous the other room
right I say performance and you all say
yay right so one two three performance
yay fantastic
all right so this talk is mostly about
performance like making up much more
faster especially in react and give our
user better user experience so how many
of you actually have seen this pitch how
many of you actually have created a
website or web application that causes
this page how many of you not have done
that but then one of the rest of what
are you some people the hand that's all
alright so we're gonna talk about this
and you know that sometimes it happens
you see it and you click and then
suddenly some stuff doesn't work and
then suddenly they were like repeatedly
very fast and that's the time where our
user is very frustrated you know
especially including ourself so we're
gonna have today we're gonna explore
different different options today like
we're gonna talk about parallel
computing vs concurrency I know that the
react also has a new experimental mode
right now called concurrency mode but
this talk is can be you later can
understand how they are implementing it
stuff but this is mostly about new api's
in the browsers like web workers this is
not new but webassembly worklets and
serviceworker so what i'm trying to do
in this talk is i just want to make it
so practical so I want you to go out
after the talk and then open on your
laps
and try to implement right away no
Theory no boring stuff just technical
itself an implementing code right away
so before that let me introduce myself
my name is Majid I'm flying from Oslo
I'm a passionate software developer just
like all of you and in my spare time I'm
doing a lot of stuff my hobby is Ronnie
conferences meetups and leading the
communities it's a very interesting to
me also I've written a book about
progressive web app but about our
enemies angular don't worry and I'm
mostly talking about performance
PWI progressive web apps and flutter so
let's get into that
what is parallel computing when we are
talking about power computing we're
talking about multiple entities that
they are doing different tasks or they
are working on the same task and
compared to concurrency when we are
saying concurrency that means we have
one entity which is working on different
tasks like these picture are
self-explanatory so how does it work
like in the browser we all know that in
the browser we have single threaded
JavaScript running in the main thread
right everything isn't only in one
thread and that's the bottleneck and how
it works the way that it works is that
we have event queue we have multiple a
lot of events queuing in this line and
then they execute it getting completed
and then go away and the next one comes
so that's that's where the problem
starts when we have a long even
happening that everything is blocking
because the even needs to be get
completed before we move on but what a
kind of option we have to solve this
problem
the first option is gonna be web workers
so web workers are around for like
around maybe 10 years or so how many of
you know about web workers almost
everyone expected and how many of you
used web or here less than 10 percent
and I'll show you why you don't use it
and hopefully after this presentation
you're gonna use it so we know web
workers that day in browser they spin up
a new another instance of JavaScript
engine and then you have a different
thread and it runs everything there and
the way that they communicate with the
main thread is we are the messaging
system right and this is how it works so
you have your browser event queue and
you have your web worker message queue
you send your message to the web worker
it takes care of your events execution
and then once it's done
it can come back again to the main
thread alright so but isn't it like this
is a concurrency the varies the
parallelism well
different devices these days have
different course like multicores right
nothing is stopped OS to run this thread
in different course and that's when
parrot comes that's when the parrot
computation actually happens but do we
know that as a web developer no we don't
know that but it may happen so let's get
into some use cases for web workers you
can think of like very heavy computation
in in the browser so you can hold off
these heavy computation to your worker
thread get it to work and then get the
result back to the main thread like an
example could be a very huge list that
needs to be sorted it's like blocking
right if you use a for loop it's
blocking the main threat so how it works
the way that it works is that you have
main thread you have working thread so
you need to send a post message in code
that means after you instantiated your
worker
web worker you're gonna have you're
gonna send the message to the worker as
like this example and then once you send
the message in a worker you listen to
the message event you get the message
and react or execute the things that you
need to do here's an example and once
it's done you send back the message to
the main thread and the main thread
again you need listen to the worker
message which is coming and then get the
result and then do something it is for
instance set the state in react to
re-render your UI okay that's not very
very interesting that's the reason 90%
of this room doesn't use web workers but
can be
do it better isn't it better like to get
access to the function directly from a
thread the working thread like it's very
easier right instead of having all of
these posts messaging around just
directly call a function in worker
thread yes it's possible
that's where comlink library comes in a
library from Summa a Google web advocate
in which he actually created this
library a few months back so how it
works so in your main thread you'll see
that how this gets easy in your main
thread you're gonna have again you need
to instantiate your work here but this
time you just use comlink to proxy or
wrap it and then once it's wrapped then
you get access to your object or
function you should exposed in the
worker and then you can immediately call
that function that's a promise based
function you can await for that and then
get the result
it looks like it's synchronous way of
programming right way easy so I have
thread worker let's imagine now that I
have by the way you need to import this
package for sure so in the main thread
I'm gonna have service and these
different functions which I'm exposing
to the comlink
from the comics all right let's see in
react how this could help one of our
problem for instance in react
application to make this move so we
create we had a use case that we needed
we had like a 3,000 an array with 3,000
member which we needed to sort and this
is very common use case right so it
happens there are multiple different
approaches to fix
the performance issue here but I'm I'm
just going to not to optimize everything
and try to use just a web worker to see
how it works so what we did is that we
just wrapped our work here which is
which has the function to sorting the
list and it looks like when I click in a
button I just call the function from
worker and get the result which is a
sorted array back to the main thread and
my work here here is simply a function
just has two for loop like I said we
didn't optimize it that is on purpose so
let's see actually how it works
you see when I click on ascending with
Weber here my animation for that little
circle
it doesn't stop and it works but when I
click on a main thread to sort then it
blocks the UI that means an animation
doesn't work it stops and then it works
all right
was it easy
well assembly why webassembly because
it's possible now that's serious I have
some question here so when I say
webassembly just say it loud like when I
say whatever somebody what do you think
what is the first thing comes to your
mind
say it loud rust fuzzum pineapple
Mozilla see machine code I didn't
understand what you say yeah alright
yeah you're right or maybe you've heard
like represent beliefs fast well look
into that maybe it's not that fast but
let's see generally webassembly you know
that the purpose is that you write
different languages in different
languages and then you compile it
similarly that can be run in browser
right and when we talk about web
assembly well the first language is that
it comes to mind is C C++ and Ross which
they have a very good support for azzam
or web assembly so but are we as a
JavaScript developer or or web developer
let's say maybe we are not very keen to
deal with C or C++ I'm not saying that
you cannot we cannot but that is not
something we are used to it right so
maybe there should be a better way to
deal with that and maybe that's the
reason we are not going to use web
assembly there is assembly script well
we as a JavaScript developer if we no
type of script how many of you know type
squid then all of you can use assembly
script
so in assembly script actually comprised
a strict type of type of script to
webassembly
so draw streak types for web assembly
which needs to be only used in that
assembly script and then that can be
compiled to
vasin so let's have a look it makes it
very easy for us to use assembly script
so how first when you setup your project
for writing web assembly you can
literally download it from NPM first of
all and then you can instantiate your or
initialize your application to create a
new application right then you get a
bunch of folders and files and
everything is ready for you to write
your web assembly code your at assembly
script code so here is where you can
write your function so you see here it's
a very simple function right now
I wrote a Fibonacci recursive version of
Fibonacci to test like how performance
is webassembly
and I wrote it in assembly script so
it's a very simple function and you see
that I am using some of the type that
are not in typescript these are the type
that are dedicated to the assembly
screen to the web assembly so
there are multiple other types to which
you need to get familiar with that
luckily they are not that hard because
we as a developer are familiar with most
of them you still need to deal with
memory maybe assembly scrip but the way
that you need to deal with memory in
assembly scrip it's very easy compared
to C and C C++ and other languages and
in a new that's that's a news in a new
version of web assembly which browser
vendors are working in a new standard
there might there will be actually
garbage collection and that means we
don't even need to do this later when it
comes to the browser so and at the end
when you wrote your functions or all of
the things that you need or maybe some
converter or everything the only thing
that you need to do is you need to
compile your assembly script to Bassem
just with one command line it's just npm
run is built alright so you get multiple
files and these files optimized are
ready for production and these are for
debugging mode so i have my resume ready
who has already worked with plasm so
okay you know that if you want to use
vadym there are if you want to
instantiate wisdom in the browser there
are some things that you need to do and
maybe it's not that interesting or not
I'm not saying it's not easy but it's
boring stuff but if you use assembly
script it makes it easy for us to fetch
the resume and expose it to the main
threat here so the only thing that we
need to do is we need to import this
function from this library loader and
then fetch your atom and expose the
services that you exported from assembly
script in this case I had my
to function which fibonacci one is my
interest so I also wrote a JavaScript
version of that function surprise same
function without type it's the same
function so I wanted to measure like
what is the performance of the
JavaScript version compared to the
Assembly's conversion like webassembly
version of that particular function for
me so I did a measurement here so here
is where I'll show you the measurement
shortly but here is where I say when we
say fast we don't have to accept it
right away we need to measure first
maybe for that particular case it's not
fast for you or for me or for that
particular case so I did a measurement
here that was a very simple function and
I thought that okay let's do that for
this number I ran two functions and it
was fast for the first time when I ran
the assembly at the webassembly version
it was seven times faster for the first
time but for the second time when you
run when I run the function then the
execution time was fairly similar like
very similar so here is where I actually
run this for the first time you see the
time here and without webassembly the
time here is around seven times slower
without webassembly alright so you know
type of sweep you now know some types
then you can write your some of your
logics and maybe some codec coder or
something in assembly screen now and the
third option
it's portlets
who know what is worklets good almost no
one work let's are a light version of
web workers so immediately comes in my
mind okay they run in a different threat
like a worker thread right so that's
good and the way and what it does it
just gives us an ability to access low
level of rendering engine like a graphic
render engine like CSS engine or audio
processing engine that is very cool so
that means I can do many things I can
get access to the low-level and gene and
then do some stuff there are multiple
different worklets available for work
available in the browser we have paint
animation layout and audio okay except
paint the rest doesn't have a very good
support in browsers but the paint API
support is much better at least we can
start playing with that and and run some
a cool heavy like maybe animation in the
browser and let's let's look into that
when we say paint I'm talking about CSS
paint API and that is also known as
Houdini paint workers worklet so let's
see how it works like web worker you're
gonna have a different JavaScript file
you write your function to draw
something to render like paint something
in the browser like in this case I want
to create a check board and actually
render it there behind my background
page alright that's good so I registered
my paint this is a simple function here
to create that and then here and my
application I just said okay please
add this function for rendering the
background fill my application and then
when I when it's instantiated I can have
paint function add my check board
function to it and then I get a
background image it just writes my
background image in JavaScript let's see
in practice this is how it looks so it
so the rendering these custom background
image is happening in a different thread
it doesn't even block the main thread so
you can do you can I'm sure now you get
a lot of other ideas like how we can use
this API so another cool a may be
example here which I didn't react is to
generate these QR code on the fly
without locking the main thread some
writing I'm actually rendering the QR
code right away with worklet changing
everything it doesn't like the main
thread at all because it's happening in
different thread and as you see here the
animation is also always working so that
means my browsers is ready for user to
do whatever they want and the last
option serviceworker you may say okay
serviceworker is not something dedicated
to like main thread or maybe you've just
react over here you're right
serviceworker is a bit different from
others you cannot use serviceworker
directive calling and or communicating
with main thread maybe you're right but
why I am interested of serviceworker I'm
gonna talk about it of course I need to
talk about it because I'm a PW a lover
so let's talk about it and see the use
case of this web service worker I call
this a brain of PW a progressive web
apps
who knows what is progressive web apps
good fantastic
the more I talk to see the more I see
that people know about progressive women
the more they actually implement all of
the functionality for that that's
awesome
so I have a full talk about Service
Worker which is linked here you get this
slide later don't worry about it
so again it's built on top of web worker
okay a type of web worker but the
difference is that service worker as you
may know or may not know it's like it
acts like proxy right okay proxy it is
interesting what does that mean that
means the request and respond can come
to your service worker first and then
you can manipulate these responses or
requests but how does how can that help
us to actually have some parallel
computation okay let's get into that
let's imagine that we register a service
worker we have a already a service
worker registered and we have everything
set up all right we can do some stuff on
the fly because you can catch the
respond and request request and then you
can actually respond so let's see here
an example which a friend of mine did
chemist so in this case what was a
scenario you have by the time that this
example was made there was only support
of epi in chrome and no other browsers
right who know who doesn't know what is
web P where P is an another type of
image compression like JPEG but maybe 30
percent more compressed right and also
supports a transparency like PNG
we they wanted to use actually web P all
of their images because it was way
smaller in terms of size okay great but
what about other browsers okay one
option was like to load different file
for different browsers right but another
option was okay let's catch
let's intercept all of the requests and
see if they are a web be filed and he
wrote actually used some libraries C
libraries and he wrote a function that
decode those files and respond to the
main thread like respond to the
application with encoded of this web P
so the application could actually show
the picture even though browser didn't
support web P that is cool
so in in serviceworker well it also runs
in a different thread that's good so you
can you can have masam do these stuff
and manipulate your respond and return
the response to the main thread there is
a sample code and link to demonstrate is
also added to the slides
let's summarize it there was some button
like with web workers which we now
realize that comlink is a library can
can help us to make it easier to work
with web workers web assembly may not be
easy to work start working with C and
Ross and those other languages and if
you don't have time to learn those
languages you already know typescript
you can start using assembly script
service worker and worklets there are
also different running and different
thread which can help us to compute
different scenarios for us and that's it
thank you very much for listening to me
if you have any question
we around to catch me I'll answer
[Applause]
you